welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host Hisham azuz and in this week's
episode I was joined by Harry Wright and
Henry Stevens who both founded a
recruitment business called Talk
Consulting they've been building their
business for three and a half years
starting the business just before covid
so we talk about everything from the
early days some of the biggest setbacks
that they had how they overcome them
what they learned from them enjoy the
episode
Harry Henry welcome to the podcast hello
thanks for having us as I was saying
we're in the in the new in the new spot
we're in the podcast Studio I feel real
professional it's very cool it's very
good uh thanks uh for making the trip
down
um so I guess I'm gonna I always like to
start with a million pound question
which I know you guys have definitely
been on a journey to really think about
when hiring for your own recruitment
business but just for everyone listening
just to give everyone a bit of context
so both uh Harry and Henry actually
started recruitment on the same day yeah
uh worked in recruitment for two years
before uh starting your own recruitment
business talk consulting which you
started uh three and a half or so years
ago
um so your first year in business was
2019 where you are today is you're
around nine people
um and we're going to talk a lot today
about that business journey in the
entrepreneurial Journey that you boys
have been on cool yeah go for it but uh
Henry let me come to you first with with
this question so in your opinion what
characteristics and traits do you really
thing make up a highly successful
recruitment consultant in today's market
is is the key part yeah so for me this
is something we've thought about highly
when we've been recruiting recently
because
going back to the old school way of
thinking about it you would always look
for like someone in sport or someone
who's you know highly competitive me and
Harry have changed our opinion on this
now and and for us we just look for two
things how adaptable that person is in
certain scenarios and then secondly in
terms of their willingness to learn that
are two things I think that
fundamentally make a solid recruiter if
you can be adaptable in situations where
adverse things happen to you and you've
got a proven track record of that
happening then you can roll that over
into recruitment quite easily that's
transferable and then the learning part
that ability to be able to implement
training is the most important thing in
recruitment because we can teach you or
you can teach or anyone can teach anyone
to do something it's whether they can
actually Implement that into their work
if you can't do that then you can't do
recruitment adaptability and willingness
to learn yeah Harry you want to add
anything to that yeah
um I don't want to go for the textbook I
resilience or anything like that but it
you really start to see the personality
traits on people when it starts going
wrong so I know
and we try and get an example of that in
in the interviews don't we like tell
them something you're bad at and if they
give you a really like thought I honesty
thought
that's not true it's when people are
honest and and kind of go into what
they're really bad at you think you're
pretty self-aware so you're gonna be
able to like think
like if we certain task not done that
very well how can I tweak that and get
better and for me that's that's a big
thing because like academic like
accolades degrees and stuff like that
it's great but if you freeze as soon as
you pick up the phone it's great nice
one but yeah do you do you look for just
curious I've been speaking to a lot of
people about this recently so you're in
your example there yeah do you look out
for people and it's a red flag if they
go this is really difficult time for me
and it was because of this so it was
their fault or it was that rather than
this is what I could have done or yeah
yeah definitely when when we asked that
question or
kind of says I've left here because of
this
if you get a really honest answer this
is what I probably could have done
better this is what I did you think I
like you yeah it whenever everyone
else's fault that's what the doctor yeah
yeah I think because I think there's
this accountability responsibility piece
yeah then I I think there's a real
percentage of people younger people that
may not necessarily have that I'm in a
boatload you know what I mean yeah and I
I think that's something in the like
even now in the market when say you're a
recruit recruiting consultant you've
been in the industry for one two years
and you're trying to move some of the
some of the posts you see now from like
recruiters want in new positions yeah
yeah
you've just got to take accountability
for your situation and if and if you if
you're doing really really well in a
company they're gonna try and retain you
so don't like don't try and make out the
company's forcing you out if you're
building like quarter a million clear
the year because it's just not gonna
happen so Henry let me come to you to
start this off like what gave what gave
you guys confidence to start this
business with two's experience like I
think some people may go yeah it
probably isn't enough some people start
with less but what gave you boys uh
confidence just because a lot of people
say they're going to start their own
recruitment business but don't what gave
you guys confidence to take that leap it
in complete honesty we were so naive
there's no there's no other way of
saying it so we were
so naive we thought cool if being
completely honest we were going to do it
we first thought about doing recruitment
on an Excel spread yeah we don't need to
CRM
this is the serious
um but for me and Harry it was the fact
that we knew that we had strengths that
complemented each other so when it comes
down to recruitment the business
development client side I can cover
that's my strength and Harry stylist was
before
um we built a business was candidate
side so we knew that we could tailor up
together and make a success of of
something we also noticed a gap in the
market didn't we so we obviously uh oh
you don't know but we worked solely
contract
um
and
you did a Northwest I did Southeast and
there was a big gap of like the 40 to
90k perm jobs that all my clients were
hiring for but we wouldn't touch them
weren't allowed to touch them because we
did contract and they were crying out
they were like but there's no
recruitment companies that will work
these jobs me and Harry were sat there
thinking okay we know that contract in
terms of reoccurring revenue is a more
valuable business but as a foundation to
get going let's just Hammer this market
and it was
it was buoyant wasn't it like the first
year was was unbelievably busy because
we couldn't believe that so many
companies don't tap into this market
we've got a few more competitors now and
a few new companies have popped up
because I think unless you're at the
exact search level then you're not
touching jobs Circle less than 100K and
then all the other jobs below that the
only real way of making money before now
in engineering was was contract so there
was this Market that was just left wide
open and we were confident that with me
on BD and Harry on delivery we could we
could nail it off and thankfully three
and a half years later we're we're still
there so it's a pain in the picture then
so 20 so when you start the business
what month in 2019 yeah we started in
May 2019
um we came like obviously we came up
with the idea of the business before
that
um but we'd left our previous business
and Covenants and stuff yeah yeah of
course so may 2019 and it was just
YouTube for the first year right yeah
yeah me and Harry we hired off we hired
our first employee at the back end of
2018 19. just before Christmas yeah
um and yeah that was a again it was just
a continue it's just been a continual
learning curve yeah neither of us have
ever like run businesses before we've
done bits but not to this level and I
think every single thing we've done has
been a massive learning curve yeah I'd
love to have a conversation with myself
three years ago because going back to
your question I think
it was naivety but we're pretty arrogant
as well yeah we can do it two years I'll
probably
well I don't regret anything at all but
I would probably do a bit more planning
what was what was the plan for the first
year then Harry like what was your like
looking back that first year oh we just
thought oh yeah we're just gonna we'll
buy her two laptops we'll get some
phones we'll just bill that was it that
was the business plan that was the
business plan we opened that laptop on
day one
loaded up VIN Terry because we bought
spent all the money on Ming Jerry yeah I
mean like right on no candidates just
all zeros I was like right
now
again we can't ring again we can't ring
him I
um this is and this isn't true like it
is yeah but the funniest bit was after
three days Harry said what have you been
doing and I said well I've been building
the website maybe we need a website so
Henry has a thing
he hasn't even doing history
he's got a thing Henry where he's great
at BD and he'll smash out BD for a few
hours and then he'll find a job nothing
to do with recruitment like putting a
shelf up like cleaning the fridge like
everyone that talk will vouch for me
yeah they will and they're just doing
that day one started building a website
said no one knows who we are they're not
gonna I'm not gonna go on the website
let's get some money we have no money
yeah so we in terms of how we like and
that was the other thing we'd
self-funded the business so the business
has no backers has no investment it's
just it was me at man Harry's money so
yeah how much runway did you give
yourselves
four months four months yeah I think we
gave ourselves four months which again
was one of those things I think if you'd
gone back now in hindsight 25 Garden on
it yeah you we would have we would have
said to ourselves okay well let's save
up a bit longer and do something
um does what we do now we run our
business on like a lot longer longevity
in terms of if everything hits the fan
and that saved us in which we'll go on
to which saved us in 2020. and we said
like why why is that the advice is that
because it would you'd put less pressure
on yourself at the beginning is it just
and I also think you can say no more we
we ha we had to say yes at the start
because it was you know you're in client
negotiations and when you're working for
a big corporate it's brilliant because
you can just it doesn't matter if they
don't want to work with you you know
realistically if you're you're setting
your percentage at 20 25 and then we
were in a situation where it was like
well are we cutting our nose off to spot
our face here yeah if we don't agree
lower rates because we need to get cash
in the bank yeah we've had to do a bit
of a clear out recently bringing clients
so
we we can't work at this percentage
anymore do you want to go on our regular
rates or not some have said yeah that's
fine some haven't but that's there
that's the problem because
without planning
you have you think right oh that's a
five grand fee five grand that's another
month I'll do it I'll take 12 anything
right well I've got I've built up a bit
of a bank account now don't worry about
anything's up I need a project manager
he sat there thinking I should be
getting about 15K for this job in about
three oh wow no yeah no I know what you
mean yeah yeah no I appreciate the
honesty so I guess let me just ask you
this then Harry and then I want to
definitely find out the biggest
challenges I think sometimes people can
over plan obviously you probably
underplanned you're being honest but
like what would you say in hindsight
with what you've learned over the last
yeah two three years or whatever what
would you say for people that are really
considering taking that leap what would
you say would be the non-negotiable
non-negotiables to at least think about
have a bit of a plan around yeah rather
than I think some people can either plan
and just overthink stuff so like what
would you say like the absolutely
crucial things that maybe people should
plan that would give them a better
chance of that first year just being
less chaotic yeah so I would always be
an inch wide in a mile deep so pick a
niche
two or three job titles and one area and
stick to it don't think like oh well
I've got that's how you're doing the
northwest or London I've got a job in
Cambridge I'll take it and just stick to
what you're doing and you'll thank
yourself kind of six eight months down
the line because you'll be able to get
one candidate and send it out to four or
five places so definitely definitely
definitely do that
um I'm massive on Market mapping so you
can have all the crms and whatever you
want but Excel spreadsheet like
postcodes company names what they do and
you can literally just it's just making
patterns you spend
two weeks just banging candidates and
getting manager names leads and getting
them on New Market map that is you that
is your Goldust that's live data data is
just that's something we neglected big
at the start didn't we
but now we're kind of going back
I'm teaching rookies to build their own
markets it's almost like building a
business within a business isn't it so
data do not neglect the data I'll do it
with somebody because it's very very
lonely like we've had
shark days yeah yeah yeah that drop out
for Christmas it's I don't know why in
fact it's mentally affected me that he
did it for the first year first year he
did the things about 16 Grand fee which
in our Market is Big decent yeah and
we're all I've got a video on my phone
we're all about jumping about yeah get
in she accepts it signs drops out couch
gets like a 25k
um I still never know it off I've done
it so I'd do it with someone because
there's been days where everything's
gone wrong and just a phone call to each
other you feel ten times better I'll
just come off it so pick your partner
make sure you can be completely honest
with that person if it's you just need
unfiltered honesty
and don't forget you dare yeah
and then yeah like you said maybe give
yourself a bit more of a financial
Runway definitely than like yeah the
thing is if you haven't got it in
recruitment if you have because some
people obviously we know the models of
of some companies where they Chuck
underground at their top Bill and they
go set up a company some people aren't
that lucky the money will always come if
you get on the phone
it will always come it's not like retail
or whatever just Hardware really so
Henry what was your from your experience
what was your biggest challenge in that
first year that you maybe least expected
or like looking about what was like the
big the real the real challenge in that
first year
um mine 100 was going from an employee
to a business owner I think the mindset
of not having you having to be fully
accountable for you and there's there's
no one going to tell you to do anything
and that's the truth we came from a
company which you know we we thoroughly
enjoyed the time now but it was very
strict processes very uh tight
tolerances on kpis
strict numbers to deliver every day and
then when that when those shackles are
taken off and we're sat there me and
Harry together you know that you can
fall into a slip of going well we could
go for lunch or we can go here or we can
do this because we're free but
realistically what that does is put you
back even further and I mean you know
and that's the the truth so for me I
think the biggest challenge was was
mentally getting myself into a situation
where there's no one else that will hold
me accountable apart for myself I have
to deliver these otherwise I will be one
out of a job but also uh you know I'm
not just affecting me now I'm affecting
Harry and I also think having that that
mindset to be able to deal with
challenges which are outside of
recruitment that are running that um are
involved in running a business which we
hadn't you we hadn't done before and it
was setting that time apart outside of
work so I would say if anything we
worked more we work more now than we've
ever worked um and that would be like
going on to a tip I think if anyone set
up a business to think that they're
going to have more time
yeah that's just not true you have you
have less time
um and I think that was probably my
biggest challenge just on what what you
on that just just quickly I know for me
I I can definitely relate to that and
it's just for me I feel like it's an
ongoing thing like
I think the goal is to like 80 90 of the
time you do the [ __ ] that sometimes you
don't really feel like you want to do
you know what I mean yeah some days
you're just gonna get up and you're like
I really can't be [ __ ] with this today
but it's like how can you make sure you
reduce those days as as much as possible
but like I think people who are employed
even struggle with that if I'm honest
from my experience hold themselves
accountable all that so like how have
you got better at that like how have you
because for me I found it's about just
setting yourself up to have the best
chance of just doing the things you know
you need to do you know I mean if that's
starting with the hardest things in the
morning or like just doing the things
outside of work that I know is going to
help me so if that's working out going
gym getting good sleep in it's just
doing the things that's going to set me
up to have a better chance of going
right I'm going to smash this out even
though sometimes you're not motivated
but you've got there's no one else
holding yourself have you got better at
it yeah so I think um my biggest
strength and I was like planning okay so
I was awful
organization anyone anyone you ever yeah
anyone who would have met me two three
years ago even would have said no way he
can run a business because organization
was was everywhere I now work really
hard on ensuring organizations in place
but then I've got a plan so each day I
come into work I know exactly what I'm
going to do which takes me back to like
my my full bill in time you know you had
to have a day plan before you come in
otherwise you'd fail
um the other thing is is like you say
it's it's in it's enjoying the things
that you can do so for me I work in like
two hour blocks like Harry says I'll do
like work on BD or developing a client
for two hours and then I'll do something
else and if that means for 15 minutes 20
minutes I'm cleaning the fridge or I'm
putting a shelf up it's just my it just
resets my brain and then I go again and
it's about having that like ruthless
Focus to do the job and then okay I've
literally I've done four hours work in
two hours so that's that's helped me I
love that Harry what's been what's been
what was your biggest challenge in that
session from your experience because
oftentimes it could be different to
probably
yeah yeah
um
it's for me it's the
feeling of
it or it's all the pressure of it's all
on us that is sometimes you sit in bed
at night and thinking especially when
you first get staff you think oh my God
like I need to build this this month
because
this person's going older this guy's
bought a house I'm thinking
need to pull my finger out well yeah
dealing with the pressure of
this this is it I've put my savings into
this you can't go wrong so that's almost
like a
fear of failure Push by pushing you
forward um and as you get better and
better you get more confident in your
ability and that that goes away
obviously you're always in the back of
your mind that something could go wrong
which I think is clever but
other than that that's that's the big
one because we we've had a lot of fun
didn't we we've had lots of fun yeah
year one we had a lot of fun because
it was just us to
like we said the shackles shackles what
we say it was a good place to work
before we didn't do it but it was just
come polar opposite like middle attack
we're in Manchester
going out for launch
do one bit one uh one deal it's above 15
degrees let's go and say in Vegas
which did catch up with us but we sorted
it but this is why I wanted to come on
here with you and Harry did as well
because I just think
but we are as transparently we've got
we've got a successful business now and
yeah but yeah we've done some stupid
things we're talking about the first
year aren't we and I think it's such a
yeah from the environment you've both
been in for however long employed
different environments it's just
entirely different yeah yeah but just on
that hurray I can really relate to that
so I don't know like I feel like yeah
when it's your business firstly let's
just be real when you have your own
business even I feel like I'm
recruitment sales or whatever like your
job is literally to just eat [ __ ] and
deal with rejection like every single
[ __ ] week basically yeah but wouldn't
ensure your business sometimes those
rejections and those setbacks can make
you feel like what's the [ __ ] point
are we gonna do it are we just gonna
fail is it not going to work so I can
definitely relate to that so like for me
personally when I have those moments or
weeks the thing that I always have to do
is basically just take action and just
get back to the things that I can
control yeah because I know as soon as I
have a good conversation with a new
customer or whatever like that quickly
goes away yeah so what what do you do
you to like make sure that I know you
said you've got Bella because you've now
got more evidence to go no no we can get
through this because this happened and
now we get through but I think some
people that can really eat them up and
it holds them back how do you get better
at not letting that overcome you so
I like to to be honest I like to pride
myself that I'm pretty good at handling
when something bad's happened
um for an example we were um a victim of
some fraud weren't we he was a victim of
some fraud yeah but
um
sorry
but basically we paid an invoice and
they went right it wasn't oh [ __ ] really
yeah yeah they had a real website for
the company we were supposed to be
paying whoever this person was had
hacked their phone so when you ring the
number you ring that real company oh
[ __ ] the money just got into that so
anyway
I'm big on
well number one nobody's dad right cool
yeah no one's Dad so we can saw it and
then it's everything I can control yeah
right well I'll worry about that I can't
control this guy's not turned up this
has happened the system's gone down
the fraud
it's gone nothing to do about now let's
move forward so Henry's very like
his things like empathy and he's good at
that sort of stuff for his own
well that's just let's just get [ __ ]
done yeah I think so dealing with it
it's literally very similar to what you
said I stepped back like a lot of the
time when me and Henry are in a
situation we're speaking Henry does a
lot of the talking and I sit back and
kind of take in so
assess it
can we control this situation or control
the outcome yes right what do we need to
do I'm quite like
pragmatic yeah the word like that's
something I think about things black and
white I don't really get emotional about
stuff like with work so if anyone was in
the situation we're in well we're in
starting our own business just take the
emotion out of every decision you make
because
when it comes to people yes these
emotions are not robots but decisions on
clients candidates that sort of thing
it's black and white the best thing you
can do and I think I don't know about
you guys but it's a constant Journey as
well as like you can sometimes fall into
like you almost feel like your business
is you if you get what I mean like it's
your identity yeah so like if if talk
Consulting another had an absolute Mega
month you're absolutely Sky High but
then if you have a [ __ ] month yeah it's
your [ __ ] yeah yeah and it's trying to
get better at disassociating yourself
with like no no when talking to someone
who's doing well that doesn't mean like
that's me doing really well I don't know
just getting better at that do you know
what I mean something we've got a lot
better at is like grounded isn't it so
and I think you know Harry's definitely
helped me with this in terms of being
like say more pragmatic probably more
more less emotional to situations
because at times we've let outside
situations affect us and then all it
does in the long run is just waste more
time yeah and that's really you look
back on it and you go all right we've
just wasted loads of time on that which
we didn't need to do so I think like say
having that ability just to take the
emotion out of it and okay everything's
going well how do we make it better or
how do we do that again it's like the
first time a client didn't pay and we
were so annoyed angry like effect was
low remember we drew that I don't know
how long was it overdue oh like they
just no it was it was over here and then
they refused to pay and I was like
absolute rats and they were like we know
you're not a big business so you know
good luck trying to suit that stuff yeah
yeah probably not the best idea we got
in can't no down there and what was the
plan when you got there it was like an
hour and 20 minute drive we just drove I
don't know I think we're just going to
confront the MD I don't know how that
was going to go
there you go boys
HR came and met us and intercepted Us in
the foyer
we got to speak to them and then we got
to score it offside he just hid in his
room so we wasted roughly four hours two
hours driving there maybe half an hour
yeah and then it affected the whole week
because we were angry about it but then
now if that happens
pass it and it's got to go to the legal
people pass it on let me know it's done
yeah we'll move on yeah
is that sometimes people don't uh people
aren't dressing us but there's a lot of
people where how long because you guys
now obviously did pattern yep so how
long it can take for customers to pay
their invoices yeah yeah something where
that's something we're trying to drive
into the team now um as well
um is like payment terms really affect
things much much more widely than we
have in here we did contracts I think
we're on seven most of our clients on
contract were on seven day payment terms
in our own business
um or two weeks wasn't it whereas now
with some of the larger companies
because because now uh permanent
recruitment a lot of the big companies
run purchase orders you're talking like
30 60 day payment terms you know
realistically if they've got a month's
notice period or a three month notice
period and then 60-day payment times
you're not getting money for three to
five months so that going back to your
question you said earlier actually in
terms of planning for for the business
that's another thing in terms of having
more more money in a bank because you
could do a deal yeah on your first day
but it might not pay for three months
what's ended up being like the realistic
average like average pay like if you do
a perm deal what's ended up being like
the average of like obviously the the
best customers and the the right
customers will probably pay exactly when
you want them to but we've got a client
who pay us early and we love them
what's ended up being like the average
amount of time 20 21 days yes that's
good insight for people yeah we we send
all of our terms at 14 day payment terms
most of our clients are brilliant
um and yeah our average payment turns 21
days we obviously sometimes clients will
ring and go God we've missed we've met
we've missed Johnson paper and sorry can
we do it next Friday yeah that's fine
um but it's just about having that
relationship with with clients and you
know understanding that you know it's
not just the engineering director or the
MD deal whether you need to have a good
relationship with Finance as well so
that when things are going wrong or
they've missed something you can just
ring up and speak to them and you've
spoke to them before a person on the
front desk yeah you have a good
relationship whoever is you've got to
know the name be nice to them yeah
because they'll sort it out for you so
let's talk about this second year then
and then we'll get into the the most
recent uh the yeah the year just gone uh
because the second year was covered so
what I wrote down in Florida yeah
preparing for this obviously ended up a
full review by the end of 2021. yeah
I've got here and then I think why
didn't we just start with so let's just
um frame up and then you can add any
more context but obviously so you did
manufacturing engineering yeah and
basically for you guys that like you you
said to me Harry on the call like you
had what like 10 14 jobs or whatever and
then it was like yeah rubbing literally
just rubbed everyone off the board
literally and then you
um you guys basically had a certain time
period what you had like 18 Grand or
something
um and in that time back to like what
you were saying what can I control you
basically ended up focusing on the new
market that ended up sort of yeah being
absolutely crucial yeah tell us a bit
about that story because I think that
just showcases like the Journey of
having your own business and what it
takes and and what you have to yeah at
the top of mindset you have to have yeah
so I think everyone now that is gonna
that will listen to us and think start a
recruitment company things like covid
can happen like
two years ago would not never thought a
pandemic shuts down the world you've got
to stay in your house like remember we
were in there we're in that shared
office weren't me and everyone was like
oh the country's going to go into
lockdown and I remember stood up it's
been like 40 people there and I was like
can everyone stop panicking it's
physically financially not viable for
the country to shut down the following
day I was sat at home and then to Paris
was on TV and said that we can't leave
the house and I was like
not but the thing is you can't really
prepare for that there's
there's nothing you can do if we weren't
in a position where
we've done well in year one and not been
like frivolous with the money or
anything
it it would have gone so there's nothing
nothing you could do about it because
especially in our Market manufacturing
you can't manufacture anything from home
I mean so
with that
again it was a case of that day it was
the day after Boris did the
announcements it was the Tuesday I think
we were in the off we we're still going
in we went to the office and we just
rubbing all the all the jobs off the
ringing up like we're closing down yep
sorry whatever
go go and then
yeah we went home got a bit sad for a
few days and then we just said right
because
again we couldn't get any of their
grants we couldn't get any of the help
No One's Gonna Come to help us like no
one
there isn't a white horse going over the
hill is that to help us we've just got a
who is open what can't short so we're
like
uh fmcg food production Pharmaceuticals
and medical devices
they can't shop like so what we're going
to go for everyone was going for food
production so you literally like that
was saturated it was like
let's try Farm zero goals let's have a
go we have no idea about it never worked
pharmaceutical job but if you stick to
your like training recruitment so good
qualifications like confident phone
Manner and stuff like that you can kind
of wing wing your way through it so
there's not the best advice but it's
more
again we took the emotion out of it we
thought if we don't make x amount of
money in the next few months that will
be it the bank because we didn't get I'm
I'm not even
yeah we're in a shared office we didn't
qualify for the grant we didn't get the
per the self-assessment one because we
hadn't done a self announcement at this
point it was a bursary grant at
Manchester City Council we didn't they
they obviously only could give it to
like 400 companies we didn't get it so I
said to Harry we were like there is
there is nothing
um and to be fair we could have you know
we'd built up a decent buffer where it
would we had two options didn't we we
said to ourselves we have a shutdown we
go and just
um and we just don't do anything for a
few months we reduce all the bills to
the best we can and I think we said we
could get through like if it was gonna
uh go on for like 10 months I said right
we sorted then or we use this
opportunity as an opportunity because I
always am a big believer in adverse
situations opportunity arises and we we
tapped into a market which now is like
40 to 45 of the business is revenue
comes from a market which started in
covert
and I and it's it's one of my favorite
markets to work as well because I like
the pharmaceutical medical device
industry is super interesting for like
I'm a bit of a geek anyway so it's super
interesting for like nerdy people who
want to know about stuff but also there
isn't a low fee it doesn't matter
whether you work entry level stuff all
the fees are really really good and
you're well respected
um and that's something that that we've
found at times in engineering doesn't
necessarily happen yeah I think um what
we're learning covert like the Mind [ __ ]
mind set shift
um
as shaped us to the next like I don't
think would be the same company no if
that hadn't happened because
everything's going too well we did not
have to deal with
like adversity really did we because we
do deal get a job do deal get a job do a
deal um it was going too well we didn't
have was it we didn't have a drop out
until two years we didn't have a silver
warrant we didn't have a single Dropout
really in two years which is just like
we I remember a sat there going like we
were looking on on mincherry and all the
placements were still all running and we
were like hat like that's like that's an
impressive stat we were like this is
this shows that we we are doing the
right thing obviously as the business
grows and you employ people and and
things happen and obviously now that
isn't the case but I think um yeah the
second year was the best year of total
Consulting not necessarily from
financials and growth Etc but it was in
terms of how the business is going to go
forward and like say we are a much more
structured business we have a much more
Clear Vision in terms of where we want
to go but we're all so much better
directors
hey everyone a real quick one from me
this podcast would not be possible
without our amazing podcast partners
vincere and saucebreaker because you
listen to this podcast you were able to
get your hands on exclusive savings on
both of these award-winning products if
you're a growing recruitment business
you have to check out vincere who are an
all-in-one operating system for your
growing recruitment business with Source
breaker if you want to make sure that
all of your recruiters have the best
tools on the market to stand out and
beat their competition then you have to
check out sourcebreaker use the link in
the show notes in the comments below and
you'll be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products so
just do something that needs to be
practical for people and then let's go
into yeah I think then let's start
talking about that how how you feel
about the business now the things that
you've integrated in the business and
all that but I guess looking about maybe
how I'll ask you like a lot of people
and you will be helping your team now
build new markets start new markets I
know it was very much like well we've
got to do it otherwise is this an
opportunity but like looking back what
what do you think you did well
to like then that become like 45 of your
business like we're thinking of building
markets yeah I don't know principles to
doing that world you think that that
could be helpful for people yeah so
stick to the basics
um Henry's as he said on that Court yeah
he's obsessed with Elon Musk so yeah we
have a big thing of the best part is no
part so you stick to your basics in
terms of
get a good MMC marketable candidate take
it to Market
keep it simple don't you don't need to
be doing well I know it recruitment's
evolving and changing but
there's people who will spend however
long on LinkedIn post or
I don't know a video on
um what's that software called the video
Yeah interview or one of them
um doing all that
if you're building a market that's like
the sexy stuff that comes later
stick to the basics the foundations good
qualifications make sure you're asking
that extra question
[Music]
um
questions that you might not really like
the answer to make sure they're asked
retain all the information take them to
Market that that's my best advice I know
it's not like too I'm breaking them but
that's yeah
but we that's how we work that's how we
won in in the Life Sciences Division and
obviously we're not saying we we own the
life sciences division Market but we we
got into what one of the most
prestigious companies in the UK through
Harry fill in a position that they had
open for nine months I filled it in two
weeks and we told you about this on the
call they they physically couldn't
understand how their seven other
recruitment agencies they were working
with at the time they now only work with
us couldn't fill this position how he
filled in two weeks against another
vacancy three days later we filled that
again inside two weeks they're now their
process now in-house is that every every
vacancy has to be filled inside four
weeks before that they gave themselves
six months to fill a vacancy wow so we
came in we set a process with them we've
now identified all of the recruit you
know the recruitment process and how we
do it and how we can integrate into that
business they now see the value of that
because our managers are spending so
much less time off the job recruiting
um than they were before so they're you
know they've they're making more money
even though they're spending more money
which you know in around about ways is
is what what recruitment is about it's
about improving increasing the the
capacity of what the managers can do in
terms of their day-to-day job while
reducing time off it and then like
balancing the cost and that's what we do
you need to understand the value that
you add yeah because if you don't
understand it as a recruiter you're not
going to be able to put like give the
message over to your client
um like I still get calls from
recruiters that haven't looked at
LinkedIn trying to get me jobs in call
centers and stuff so and I think
that's great well this was a this is a
shocking phone call I'm gonna be nice to
because I understand the position you're
in but
you've got to understand where your
value is we know that when talk
consulting or our Consultants call a
client and get a meeting and speak with
the um hiring manager what we offer what
we're good at
they might say can you do x y and z
no can't do that because
that's not what we do this is what we do
this is what we're good at this is how
it's going to save you time money
anything like that
and it's it's Crystal Clear then and
yeah there's no money in the water
everyone's happy it's crazy how many
concerns actually don't know that answer
that question yeah or at least they
don't get told it a lot I think looking
like and if you think about it
a lot of people are [ __ ] together doing
BD I think that is part of it yeah
definitely put clients in the pedestal
100 don't realize actually the value
that they're given if you can actually
help people really truly understand that
it's going to be more confident going
into those conversations clients clients
are PD is the best part of Recruitment
and I I don't care whether you're a
you're a delivery consultant or you do
candidates only if you go on a good
client meeting and you win the client
over and you come back there isn't a
better feeling I don't think like we
went we were able took one of our
Consultants who's transitioning from
delivery to 360 but to first meeting big
engineering company I couldn't believe
she bothered me and they were like no we
want you to come on site what you see is
I was like Wow George you've done that
really this is impressive work
when on Saturday she loved it yeah she's
like now she's like oh I just want to do
BD I'm like yeah because it's addictive
isn't it like it's the it's because it's
it's different to candidates because
you're turning a situation where you
might not win or shouldn't always win
into a situation where you win and that
in a like competitive nature
entrepreneurial Spirit whatever you want
to call it is the thing that keeps us
all alive isn't it where you go into a
situation where you're up against it
you've never met these people they might
not like you you've got to negotiate and
you come out the other end and
everything's agreed it's like that's
okay smoker so let's talk about the
third year and then like more recent
right so I guess let's just with you
guys being honest today just I guess
what we could say that when you've
really grown up as business owners maybe
and like taking the things that you've
learned
so you shared with me again correct me
if I'm wrong here but yeah I showed you
end of third year you did just under
800k revenue and you had and then you're
all about nine people today yeah yeah
obviously and then I know you have goals
to break the million this year right
yeah so we're we're we're 10 heads now
aren't we so yeah we're just I'm sorry
yeah yeah
I think I think for for us this this
year was like an investment year wasn't
it we we sat down
um and we do every year we sit down we
we plan now for the future yeah we do
um and we we set time aside for that and
I think we we said that we wanted to
invest a significant amount of time into
the com into the staff that we have and
I think sometimes companies get
um what's like pride gets in the way
sometimes and you think oh I need to we
need to grow and we need to grow and we
need to grow we need to hire more people
because that looks good forget what
other people think what you need to do
what we said to ourselves didn't we is
we want to invest our time into the
staff we have so that we get them to a
point where they're billing consistently
but not only consistently they're
they're achieving the targets that they
want to achieve people are motivated via
different things and especially in
recruitment now it's definitely
modernized a lot more in terms of it's
not just commission lunch clubs and
holidays anymore there's so many other
incentives that people want that can
that you can give to people so we sit we
sat all of our guys down at the start of
the year didn't we and we did like a
financial planning with them and what
they want to achieve and what they want
to buy and how we're going to do that
and we implemented that into the
business and me and Harry were very
conscious that we were not going to grow
the team until we got that Core Group to
where they wanted to be because we
believe in the group that we have and
that's something that over the third
year in the business we work really hard
on
um which yes stifled growth in terms of
um in terms of head count but the
company in terms of efficiency now is
much better yeah and then we then have
redundancy in the business well we can
come away to London today and we know
that the office is going to be run and
there's going to be you know no one's no
one's not gonna know what to do or have
someone to speak to or you know are
going to get lost and that that for us
is like now while we're in next year
gonna be able to really sort of drive
forward the growth because we have that
foundation so because my question was
going to be and you sort of answered
that they're definitely one of the ways
in terms of financial planning with the
team really understand what they want
decide that you're going to reinvest in
the team but my question was going to be
like what what else do you feel like the
decisions you've made that have made you
more grown up now in business or things
you've integrated so that's I don't know
if you want to add anything now in terms
of you think that maybe yeah things that
you've really decided to do that if you
know what that was a good decision or
I'm really pleased that we've then ended
up doing that yeah so
it kind of links in with what Henry said
but I'll go into a bit more details so
we
used and we can admit me and Henry can
admit that we get a lot of stuff wrong
um we used to
set goals and
incentives and achievements that we like
and then yeah yeah and then and then I
think well we've got two 21 year old
girls in the team they don't want to go
do what I want to do so that that
meeting that we have it's we literally
plan to the penny how much money do you
want to earn yeah to be happy almost
obviously
don't say to me
100 Grand okay why
um but if you're happy with earning 80
grand let's see what we've got to do and
we've we've always been big on ratios
but we've really pushed it this year
haven't we like everyone fills out their
um ratios for the month and we get an
average so once we let's for example Ben
says I want to earn x a month okay cool
we can sit and literally break it down
you need to send
23 CVS to drop and you will achieve that
like data data um like management has
just gone through the roof but
um I think
I'm pleased that we did the kind of
surveys and the financial planning
meeting with the team because
it's not like a dictatorship of me and
me and Henry sit there and go Bill Bill
yeah we want to go to a B for us on that
when
the guys I don't know what I'll save up
for a house with a boyfriend or I mean
something like that so yeah knowing you
know in the team
on a really personal level they're not
just kind of a number on a spreadsheet I
know we're a small team but it's like
a little family isn't it almost like
they can talk to us about everything so
really really focus on the people you
know is what was done this year so year
one was just get cash in the bank year
two was survive covered wanna get
through the other side and year three
has been Foundation the building the
core yeah you've really committed to
processes like what I love about what
you just said it may sound like really
boring or like I don't know I don't know
people almost like make people scared of
the word kpi now and stuff don't they
but because of the world that I'm in one
of the biggest challenges that I always
hear from recruiters when we're sort of
on boarding them talking about their
learning and stuff is like time
management and actually what that means
what they're actually saying is like
I've there's a lot of stuff that I need
to manage and I don't know what to
prioritize but when you make it when you
sit down with your manager and you know
one what your big goal is and why that's
important to you and then you really
make it really simple of like from how
you're performing at the moment if you
do these each month it should mean that
you hit your goal and then you've just
made it really easy and simple and
understand for them to understand yeah
and in recruitment you can end up just
getting lost in all this different stuff
so that's what I love about that a lot
of sometimes recruiters actually need
that like if they just have complete
Clarity on this is what I this is what
I'm aiming for if I do this and I should
be in a good position but a lot of
people don't have that do you know what
I mean so I think I think that's a great
Insight like we do that we do that as
well don't we like in our process we say
to people like just make each of this
each of the processes as simple as
possible and therefore you can you're
going to have better results we were
saying this on the call to you I think
you know something that happens is
people over complicate things further
down the line because they feel like
they have to in order to be more senior
or to be have done have done anything
for longer you need to make the process
more more complicated and that's why
like our Mantra is like not different
just better and that that's true just do
all those sections better and you will
have better results I love that I've got
two more two more things before we
finish our last year definitely on a
torture about uh the journey with the US
so far this year because I think a lot
the people who've taken on that yeah a
lot of fun Journey but I guess let me
just ask you uh just quickly I know like
we said about some of the you touched on
it but I know that one of your biggest
challenges we've just spoke about some
of the great things you've ended up
implementing but it has been hiring yeah
and it's just obviously just always it's
just ironic and that yeah do Recruitment
and it's hard for yourself but like what
have we got to share on this for people
like what what have I think what you
shared with me on the call was you've
now really ended up committing to people
that don't have recruitment experience
or maybe not loads of recruitment
experience
um so I don't know what you want to
share on this on like the real pains
you've had to go through on hiring for
your business and why that's been
difficult yeah so I think we we took to
hiring like anyone would take to hiring
let's let's look for someone who's done
this job before integrate him into our
team and show them our processes and
they're going to succeed
that is not the case and over again yeah
really naive one that you know
necessarily I think
um experienced recruiters can be quite
you know are notoriously more difficult
because you know they have their own way
of doing things and you know you're not
you don't want to teach them to suck
eggs and you want to give them that
respect but also integrate them into
your business so we made a conscious
decision maybe 18 no 14 months ago-ish
we are only going to hire people now who
unless we personally know them who I've
got no experience and we look for we
look only as well on now for people with
like that that attitude and willingness
to learn in an interview and and that
that like the the
personality traits of ability to adapt
don't we the same thing though yeah
because you can't you cannot um
unfortunately if they're a grad or have
never done recruitment before what can
you ask them in an interview which is
going to tell you that they can do
recruitment there is nothing so you're
hiring 100 based on do I believe this
person can do the job do I want to
invest money in them that's all you can
hire on so we've made our recruitment
process dead simple our interviews
probably last the actual interview
probably last 20 minutes we don't get
them to sit with a team for a bit and
see what the team think of them because
that's massive like the cultural impact
of people
um and yeah hiring has been very
difficult but you have to understand
with that way of hiring you are going to
hire people that are not going to work
out and I think something that we
struggle with at times isn't it is is
cutting people early enough because
they're saying we spend a lot of time
with people we're a smaller company it's
then difficult to go right well this
person isn't working out but let's
invest a bit more time into them even
though you know six weeks before you
suck them that they they couldn't do the
job you should have so I I think hiring
is is the most difficult thing in
recruitment uh in terms of our own and
recruiter business and retain and like
and finding good good candidates to come
but when you do we retain them like and
you will and you have to you know you
have to retain good good talent yeah
invest in them all right what's bit what
would say you're from your perspective
and your experiences were some of the
biggest horror mistakes you've made like
internally
um we used to try and I think because I
could admit we were pretty bad at
interviewing at the start
um we almost tried to make it like a
Lads club didn't we we're trying to get
that typical
recruit a personality even with some of
the girls we we hired and
it we're all there for the wrong reasons
um I think everyone we've got now
their personalities are completely
different but they're all friends so I
think we've nailed it with these guys
but um
the challenges for me is
because it's
because it is grad Recruitment and like
Henry said they can't they can't tell
you anything of substance really like I
can do this I can do this it you are
just rolling a dice and you need to
separate
from do I like this person or
is this person going to be good for my
business like I think like we've sat in
interviews before and we've told the guy
like
make me really like and everything but
we're not don't think it's going to work
but
12 months ago we'd have been scared like
probably more than 12 months 18 months
ago two years ago we'd have been worried
about offending them like thinking like
I actually just would go for a parent
with this guy I don't see what in in the
business sort of thing but it's it comes
with reps doing loads of interviews
um and the big thing
since we introduced a team
um
like meeting them at the end we
literally get them all in the same time
literally everyone crams into the
boardroom
that has been a big Insight because
we've gone up here like this guy I
really like this guy then he meets the
team in the long run he didn't ask us
anything they have no questions to ask
us so it's like that's that's your team
so it's a red flag yeah are you going to
work with them sort of thing and
yeah I can admit we we've got it wrong
big time a few times but we're much more
um kind of self-aware of this ain't
working and to be fair there's only been
that many people that we've had to part
ways with who've been annoyed about it
no like
people normally it's like pretty
amicable like yeah it's probably the
right decision right so they respect it
so I feel like we've built a nice
kind of we're just environment Yeah well
yeah it's all just built on honesty so
honest with yourself that like I knew
Henry is better at interviewing than me
because I can just sit there a bit
monitor on the stone I've got the desk
and probably not that welcoming
um
but I've got better I used to just sit
back and stare at them and like just
watch and at least put people off no I
love that but yeah
um it's just reps gotta keep doing it um
it's hard but if you're hiring for a
position just book out a day go get a
full day of interviews in buy the last
few interviews you're uh you're a
monster I think people like some some
recruitment companies sometimes and
managers are afraid of like giving like
hiring responsibility away or taking
other people's opinion like we really
value the opinion that the team has and
we've we've had we've sat with people
that we're like wow they could be a
really good recruiter
um and then the team will come in and
the team like say don't get the right
feeling or they don't ask the right
questions or they say something stupid
because they all of a sudden they're
they the interview per the whatever is
the interview suit or whatever you want
to put mask comes off because they're
speaking to the team like well he's not
going to make the decision and it's one
of the best things I've ever done yeah
so who's been heading up us then
house yes all right let's I think it's
definitely let's sort of wrap this up
here on your journey and we'll talk
about what you guys are excited about
but
it's definitely been a real Trend I've
found over the last like year two years
a lot of UK recruitment companies that I
know and speak to have committed to just
doing the us or start to build out in
the USA I guess so before I wrote down
that you've been doing it from June yeah
this year yeah we've gone
kind of full time of it now I I've
neglected it in terms of
a Passover my UK patch to one of the
guys thought right let's do this
and then we needed to be back on UK so
I've been flicking in and out but we're
on it now it's been a culture shock
what's been the main difference is that
you picked up on so
the what shocked me a little bit is like
the Americans like loyalty to their
employer right everybody's open to work
everyone will speak to regret which is
good for me
um no one's ever had a bad interview
they're unbelievably polite
um so then you can't really gauge
[Music]
so that's a bit of the culture shop
because everything's super positive all
the time I'm like yeah but is there
anything that you would want to be
different no it's amazing oh God and
don't hear from them again so there
obviously was something nice like
that that was that was wrong
um
yeah that's the main one they
from a client perspective
I'm finding that it's almost like a lot
of companies don't really understand
what we do so it's like what so I'm
paying you to post a job advert and
you're gonna
just told me the people that no no I've
got a network of people that I can find
and reduce the time and all this and
once you explain it to them
they love it well that it is it's just
been the cultural difference I think
some people are just sometimes to speak
it's because I've heard an English voice
yeah I'll say I'll sit on the phone for
20 minutes so this guy and I'm off the
phone telling me like with 20 exclusive
buzzing get the terms out never in the
guy again yeah I've definitely heard
this from other people yeah because they
say sell don't they they like
unbelievable like the greatest sound
themselves as well because we do
Engineering in the US the same markets
we do in the UK they sell themselves
like hard to you like it that I think is
when I've helped you on a couple of jobs
by identifying like their key skills and
then and then their like key
achievements under those skills is
impossible to at times because they will
tell you everything you want to hear
whereas in England it's a little or not
in England should I say but in in the UK
recruitment Market in engineering it's a
lot easier to weed the ones out that are
telling you complete rubbish to the ones
on yeah yeah how quickly did it take you
to like sign tons of a client or like
what was the what was the strategy what
was the approach did you focus on a
particular state or uh yeah so we we
focused on Texas like so Austin uh San
Antonio and Houston are kind of in like
a almost like a triangle it's like 300
mile triangles so we tried there first
um
got got a few bites in terms of terms
out the door that's another thing that I
I noticed
they'll agree terms of you all day
whereas someone in the UK or Europe or
Asia wouldn't if it needed they wouldn't
these guys will agree terms all day but
there's nothing there's not a lot always
some like follow-up
um
so yeah so we started with uh Austin
obviously it's one of the fastest
growing cities in the world isn't it
um obviously got Tesla SpaceX all that
everyone seems to want to get out of
there so that was not good for you
either upsets you that I've done it but
yeah
um yeah so we wanted to do a lot of
Renewables again another new market
within talk I thought
we need Recession Proof Industries in
case because I know there's there's all
the news about yeah
that's how it's asking it every yeah but
we've not really been affected yet but
um we're always just conscious now
because of covert so we wanted
recession-proof um market so we've gone
we've gone through Renewables it's been
a slow burner
um and then we've hopped on our bread
and butter of manufacturing as well so
we've got we've got some bits on
um I actually got an exclusive design
engineer the other day so I've got to
run into it when I go back have you done
a deal yet or not no no yeah not yet how
long are you gonna give it because I
think sometimes people are like how long
should I give that to be honest and if
I'm being completely honest with myself
we say talk Consulting us start in June
properly working it
last month
last two weeks I've actually like worked
the jobs right yeah so
um we'll do a place in this month we'll
get we'll get we'll get it done this one
the average fee over there is kind of
too much higher yeah North what are we
saying because I think that's good
insight for people so what average deal
size in the UK for you guys in
manufacturing as well oh that's
difficult
um white color white color engineering
you're going to be anywhere from six to
nine thousand and we'll attending us U.S
it's 20
thousand dollars to forty right that's
mad in that but what's needs a lot of
dollar to a pound and the exchange rate
them in like that's what I'm saying
Harry Come On Son I would say to um if
anyone like is starting to recruit
company is going to jump onto the US
their notice periods two weeks one week
and two weeks so people move quick so
it's it's a short sales cycle for a lot
of gain but just be prepared if it goes
the other way for you yeah you've just
got to be resilient and move on with it
sort of thing because I think you put
your head in a pillow for a little bit
for 25k job yeah I've spoken to a lot of
people about this and I think sometimes
there's this perception online that the
people share that a lot of people making
out like the US market is easy no and my
view on that is like everything you just
said there is just there's still
challenges it's hard but the rewards was
higher yeah and that's the that's the
simple as it like no one's saying it's
easier it is challenging there's nuances
it's hard but actually the the reward is
just higher but it's super saturated you
at the US market is super saturated what
the us or UK the US you think the UK is
saturated the US market it's just
recruit it's saturated everyone you
speak to oh I'm speaking to XYZ I don't
think foreign
this sort of middle bit obviously
Chicago which is um
Detroit sorry it's um automotive and
stuff isn't it and then
it's
then there's a big desert and then then
it's like California so it's massive but
some of the states are
pretty quiet like there's not much
industry in the United States but it's
very concentrated yeah but if you're if
you're in Tech if you're a tech
recruiter than America's just going off
I would have thought
so let's write this up then boys Henry
what are we excited about mate because I
feel like you guys have been ruining
today been on a real journey but I feel
like yeah I wouldn't definitely feel
really excited for the future what
what's what we excited about yeah I'm
I'm just excited to like continue
learning for me I think it's been it's
been the best thing that I've ever done
and I would never tell anyone not to do
it um it was it's been unbelievable but
in terms of what we're really excited
about for the future I'm excited for the
development of the US one of the guys in
the team already wants to transition
into the US so we're gonna we're gonna
let him do that with Harry really
excited to see how that comes um
obviously from a growth perspective
we've got big plans for for um 2023 in
terms of what we want to achieve
um and yeah it's just that it's that
like ruthlessness now and and focus and
drive to make that to make it happen
which I'm I'm you know laser focused on
and yeah this time next year excites me
a lot in terms of where the company can
be and where everyone will be yeah how
are we excited about mate
um breaking that million pounds
um
[Music]
10K month and then we'll have our first
50k you know you have these little like
Revenue things for that yeah seven
figure business yeah we've got something
that's good
yeah doing that on the team the teammate
the team we've got right now um I'm real
I really really love them all like it's
like
I can actually
see them all being top Bellas like
so for example one of the lads Ryan he's
just steadily just going like on that
Georgia on this uh meeting the other day
this is a girl who the first day she
chucked her headset off because she's so
scared when someone answered the phone
she bought to meet him with a
multi-million company like and the
others are just all Rockets as well so I
can just see them all being like being a
bit of a lime Pit by this time this time
next year and then it's the standard for
everyone man yeah I love that yeah so
gonna be a good one Harry Henry it's
been a pleasure thank you cheers thank
you thank you so much for listening to
the episode I hope you enjoyed it and
got value from the conversation if you
did enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode